- Put this on your dash.
- Stop eating eggs next to me.
- Stop breathing next to me.
- So, where you working tomorrow?
- Same place.
- Same place, same job?
You like working at a parking lot?
- Yeah. It's fun.
- Oh my god!
You love it.
- I love it like you love eggs.
- Sick.
- Put this on your dash.
- Hey, Baller.
- [Guy] What's up?
- [Guy] What are you doing here?
- Just wanted to see what's
so special about this place.
- There's nothing
special about this place.
- Yeah. How many people usually park here?
- [Guy] I don't know, a couple.
- So like two?
- [Guy] Sure.
- [Guy] Can you clear out?
- Yeah.
- Don't worry. I got this.
- Put that on your dash.
- [Driver] Since when is
it 50 bucks to park here?
- Since now. Yeah.
- [Guy] It's not.
- Five is fine.
Put that on your dash.
- Do you not want this parking
lot to succeed or what?
- I'm a minimum wage employee here.
I don't care if this parking lot succeeds.
- Next time, just give the sign a chance.
Can I borrow your stool?
- No.
- Come on.
- [Guy] Go home.
- What do people even do in parking lots?
- They park.
- Drink malt liquor, smoke weed,
drink hard liquor.
- [Guy] No. They just park.
- No.
There's like 500 square
feet in here, right?
- The parking lot is
like 10,000 square feet.
Wait. Why does that matter?
- Yes. That will be 50 dollars, Miss.
- Very funny.
But while you've been
wasting away on that stool,
I figured out how to save the parking lot.
- [Guy] Bananas.
- No! A Farmer's Market.
- One table with some shitty fruit
does not make a Farmer's Market.
- Well, I've been tweeting
about it for the last hour.
So the other farmers should arrive soon.
- Do farmers even Twitter?
- I've also been Snap
Chatting like a beast.
So, trust me. The word's
getting out there.
Can I borrow your stool?
- No.
- [Farmer] Just set up anywhere?
- This is too much.
- Vendor's fee is 50 bucks, right?
- Oh, yeah.
Why don't you set up next to that girl?
- You got it chief.
- [Girl] Man, that drought must've--
- I don't want to talk about it.
- Hey, you have to shut this down.
- Shut it down, why?
This is awesome,
and I bartered three unripe
bananas for these babies.
- There are too many people here.
They keep asking me questions.
- You don't have to
answer their questions.
You're just the parking lot attendant.
- At a lot where nobody can park.
Look, they're taking up all the spaces.
- Just go back to your stool.
You look great in that polo.
- Did you see a goat pass through here?
- I'm picking up a very dark auroa.
Would you like me to cleanse you?
- Hey, can you review my
necklace for my Etsy account?
- You could actually just have it back.
If I reviewed it, I
would say it's terrible.
- Hey, Dude. I really got to pee.
Is there a designated area for that here?
All right. Well my take away from this is
that I could just pee anywhere then.
- Hey, no peeing in the lot!
- [Man] I've already started. I'm sorry.
Oh, it's so much pee!
- Hey! If I don't sell
those, I lose the farm.
- There's no farm.
- There's a farm somewhere.
Just 'cause you can't see it,
doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
- Britney, I'm serious.
I don't want to work any Farmer's Market.
I want to work in a parking
lot where nobody parks.
- Why would you want that
when you could have all this?
There's juice samples and crystals.
- I don't like juice samples and crystals.
- Okay, we can get different vendors.
- I don't want any vendors.
I want this place back the way it was.
- Okay. I was just trying to help.
- Help me by getting
this crap out of here.
- Am I the crap?
Am I included in the crap?
- No. You're not the crap.
This morning I had a
job that I liked and--
- And now you don't.
No, it's okay. I get it.
- Britney.
- I had to take matters into my own hands.
Your negative energy is
poisoning all of us now.
- Can I get some of that?
You know, watching you tear
into your sister like
that, hurt my feelings.
Hey.
I'm sorry.
- I don't care
- [Guy] Hey.
Hey, I have something to show you.
Remember your twelfth birthday party,
I threw up in the pool
from eating too much ice cream cake?
I actually threw up because
I was really nervous to be around
all of your older friends.
I mean.
I don't see why you can't swim
in a pool full of throw-up anyway.
It's just, chlorine water's gross.
- There were chunks in the filter.
- You're not swimming in the filter.
You think today was worse than that?
- I don't know. I mean
you ruined my reputation.
- Like, among the farmers?
- No.
Among the twelve-year-olds.
Especially, Crystal.
She was really hot.
- I had a crush on Crystal!
- Me too.
- Come on. Let me show you something.
- I'll even let you sit on my stool.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I'll take three.
- [Britney] Wow!
You did all this for me?
- I kind of did it for me.
- Holy shit! I'm awesome!
- You're okay.
- So you're not still mad
at me for doing your thing?
- It's cool. I get a new thing.
Subscribe for more wonder things.
Faking It At Work.
BuzzFeed Motion Pictures